here's a dramatization of what I think
most Hollywood conversations go like
behind the scenes nowadays
excuse me mr. Hollywood executive we
have a new script here for you to read
I felt like based on a book uh yes sir
it actually is okay here's the million
dollars it's actually very accurate
divergent is directed by Neil burger and
star shailene woodley Theo James Kate
Winslet and miles teller this movies
based on the popular book series by
Veronica Roth and what it's about is a
girl who belongs to a certain faction in
fact she's in post-apocalyptic Chicago
and all of these people there belong to
various factions some are very
courageous some are very smart some are
good with farming everyone at some
certain point in the life has to go
through a test in which it's explained
that they should be in part of a faction
based off of this test they take it's a
very mental thing and this test decides
very quickly what faction you should be
in however you're still given a choice
so the test I don't really know why it's
there it's sort of like a guideline I
guess she finds out that she is a
divergent someone who actually doesn't
fit into a specific faction that's
extremely rare and people are afraid of
divergence because they have a
possibility of overthrowing power and
all of them are executed so she has to
try to hide the fact that she's a
divergent by joining the group called
dauntless which are these warriors the
soldiers of their time and she has to
train and learn how to convince others
that she should be in that faction
despite the fact that she's actually a
divergent like I said in my intro it
seems like virtually every popular book
nowadays especially if it's a book
series and especially if it's young
adult is being turned into a movie
franchise whether it's Harry Potter
Twilight vampire Academy Mortal
Instruments the City of Bones they're
everywhere and divergent is just another
one and that's not very surprising but
you know what actually is kind of
surprising
it's actually not that bad shailene
woodley plays Tris and she's one of my
favorite actresses in recent years she's
really proved herself in movies like The
Descendants and the spectacular now and
he or she is very very good in this role
she brings a lot of
raw emotion to this character I would
like in her performance in some scenes
to that of Jennifer Lawrence and the
Hunger Games another very famous young
adult looks serious turned into movie
franchise but she really does bring a
lot of very good depth to her character
she's very convincing in the physical
aspects than learning how to fight the
training the combat all of that stuff
and she was also extremely good in the
emotional scenes Theo James as her
trainer slash love interest is okay he's
alright in the movie I think he's a
little wooden at times but he was
nowhere near as bad as other men in
certain franchises that we won't discuss
he was pretty good in the movie compared
to that Jai Courtney has this really
super badass hard-ass trainer who
doesn't take crap from anybody was
really good in this movie in fact this
is probably the best performance I've
seen from him which isn't saying much
die hurt five but he was good in the
movies what I'm saying
a disappointing aspect of this movie was
Kate Winslet's character she is a
terrific actress I've seen her do great
work and a lot of things but her
character here doesn't really have that
much to do and I mean that like she kind
of just walks in and out of scenes she
has moments where you're supposed to be
like okay I see where you're going with
this character I see how she's supposed
to be evil and I'm supposed to be afraid
of her but you're just not because the
material isn't strong enough for her
character and she doesn't have that much
screen time it's not really until the
third reel of the movie where you really
start to see what's going on behind the
scenes which I will not spoil and then
you're like okay I see why this woman
needs to get slapped by hope and so then
you're like she's a good actress that
she's a good actress the thing I enjoyed
the most about this movie and the thing
that made the two-and-a-half hour
runtime not unbearable was the character
of Tris and she was played terrifically
by shailene woodley some of the film's
action scenes are done well even though
there is a bit of close-up shaky camp
stuff which I'm becoming used to
unfortunately it's just going to be
there but it's not overbearing at all
there's some really well-done scenes in
this movie some of the action is
convincing there's some cool stunt work
as well too and even though you can kind
of take it and compare it to a lot of
these other things like the various
classes like Slytherin and the Harry
Potter's and all the districts in The
Hunger Games and here we have the
factions and you know it's there are
similarities but it's enough of its own
thing to warrant interest and I think it
was well-made enough and why
acted enough also to warn interest even
though the central romance that develops
is kind of wooden and I didn't really
care so much about it and some of the
characters are underused I was
surprisingly interested in this movie
and I had a good time watching it it's a
little too long but my fiancee who read
the book says that it kind of had to be
because they already took out so much
stuff and they had to keep certain core
things so I understand that I'm gonna
give divergent of B it's actually not
too bad I would suggest checking it out
I'm hoping the sequels are a little bit
better then we can get more into the
characters and see where it's all going
and I think that'll happen as I said my
fianc I did read the book and she has
decided that she would like to start
reviewing books from time to time on
YouTube she's a humongous book reader
she reads like hundreds of pages in a
couple hours crazy she reads a book so
fast I don't know how she does it but
she has done a review for divergent and
I left a link for that in the
description below if you want to go
check out her channel subscribe if you
would like to I'm supporting her it's
what I do I mean I'm her fiance I
support her I do my best I love you
honey guys thank you so much for
watching if you've seen divergent or
I've read the book what do you think of
the comparisons what do you think of the
new movie what are your thoughts on the
book are you excited to see where the
sequels go I would like to know what all
of your thoughts are thanks a lot guys
and as always if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck my next
you